So now let's see Coral in action for putting
and getting content, user-generated content, that can be distributed in
a democratic fashion and the load for both serving as a metadata
server as well as the content server can get naturally
distributed. Because of the way the Coral system works in
managing the sloppy DHT. Let's say, Naomi, who is at node number 30, has some
interesting content, and she wants to share it
with the world. So what she does, she
creates a unique signature, a key, for this
content by hashing it. And let's say that
the key that she generated for this content is 100. So now, Naomi wants to put
the key, 100, and the value, 30, indicating that this
node has the content corresponding to this key, 100. She
wants to put it out on the internet, and so she uses the Coral
system. And she uses the Coral key-based routing. The
node that she would like to store this key 100 is node
100 corresponding to David's computer, okay? Because David's
computer has node ID 100 so that's the
place I would like to keep it, but
we are following the Corals key-based routing algorithm. So
Naomi, what she's going to do is going to make a series of RPC calls to put 100,
30 key value pair. And she finds that none of the intermediate nodes are either
full or loaded. And finally, she reaches David's
computer. David also says my node is neither
full nor loaded. How can it be, because
she just created this content, 100. So this
100, key 100, is not known to the world. So nobody is at this point serving as a
metadata server for this particular key. So David is the right place to keep it,
so David hosts this particular key value pair, 100, 30. Jacques finds out
that there is this interesting video whose signature is 100, so he wants to get
it. And he knows that the likely place where it is contained is
node number 100, but once again, he is going to use the Coral key-based routing,
and he is doing a get call, and the get call follows the same key-based routing
algorithm of halving the distance to the destination.
And so we make a whole bunch of RPC
calls, finally get to the destination itself because
none of the intermediate nodes have this key
value pair. So we get to David's computer,
and David says, yes, I do have the key
value pair 100, 30, and here is the
value that you are looking for associated with the
key that you are asking about, and the
value is 30 indicating that 30 is the node
that has the content that corresponds to this
key 100. That's what Jacques is going to get
back. So then Jacques gets his response from,
from David that the value is 30, that value
indicates the node ID from which Jacques
can download the content corresponding to the
key 100. That's Naomi's computer. So, Jacques
goes to Naomi's computer and gets the content
corresponding to key 100. Naomi sends the content, so Jacques is now happy. He's
got the content that corresponds to 100. But Jacques is a nice guy too. So he
says well, I have the content. Since I have
the content, I can also serve as a proxy
for Naomi. And what I'm going to do, is
I'm going to put the key value pair 100 corresponding
to this content that is now mirrored over here.
And say that the value is 60 indicating that I'm
willing to serve as a proxy for the same
content. So I'm going to do a pull operation, and
this pull operation is going to go down, and
this pull operation is going to use the same
key-based routing algorithm. And when it gets to David,
David might say look I am not interested in holding
more than one value for this particular key. And
so if he says that I don't want to do
it then I have to retract my steps and
pick an intermediate node which said that it is willing.
Because it is neither loaded nor full for this particular key 100, so it's
willing to serve as a metadata server. We already have one metadata server, but
this guy is willing to do that for only one value, and therefore this guy
becomes a new metadata server for the same key 100. So
in this metadata server, new metadata server, we've got
this entry 100, 60 also stored. So now there are two metadata servers
that can potentially answer queries that concern this video 100. Now if a
third guy, Kamal, comes to know about this cool video that is now
propagating on the internet and he finds that the key for that is 100.
He can once again query the Coral system
for that video and he is following the same
key-based routing algorithm of Coral, and trying to get
towards David's node, which is node 100. So he's
going to follow that, but when he does
that he hits this intermediate node and this guy
says, you know what, I've got the key that
you're looking for and the value that is associated
with this key is 60. So Kamal doesn't have to go all the
way to this metadata server. He can get the answer for his query, get
100, from this intermediate node itself which returns a different
value. Different from Naomi's address.
Namely node ID 60 that corresponds to the new good Samaritan, Jacques,
who's also willing to serve as a proxy for the same video content. So 60 gets
return to Kamal and Kamal can then go to Jacques and get the content from, from
Jacques. And that way you see that the
origin of this particular video, which started at
Naomi, is now propagated to Jacques. So the
origin server need not get overloaded and of
course Kamal will turn around and become a good Samaritan himself and say that
he is willing to serve as a proxy also. So his key value pair
entry gets into another intermediate node. Now
we've got three nodes that can serve
as metadata server for this particular key
100. Not just the original metadata server node,
David's computer, but intermediate nodes that also have become
part of the metadata server network for this particular key 100. And
similarly, there is no origin server overload also. Because now
the content itself has gotten distributed
in several proxies. And all of these proxies
have dynamically gotten the content, and have shared their willingness
to serve as proxies. So if a new node wants to get the same video 100, when
it makes its get operation, that get operation is going to traverse the
network, and either hit David himself or
hopefully one of the intermediate metadata servers.
And that way the request for the actual content may go to different
content providers dynamically as the system evolves. So as a result you can
see that the metadata server load is distributed. And the origin server
is also not stressed. That's the nice thing about the Coral sloppy DHT approach.
So the key takeaway in the Coral approach, is that even though an individual
request may have a little bit more latency because we're not trying to reach
the desired destination directly, but going through
some intermediate hops. In particular halving the
distance to the desired destination. You're going
to increase the latency a little bit,
but we are doing that in the common good that in these kinds of environments,
giant scale services, big data, large numbers of users, and content suddenly
becoming popular, all of this dynamism has be dealt with in a
system that is as vibrant as the internet. And Coral is a step towards that
by reducing the stress on the origin server, as well
as reducing the stress on the metaservers by naturally distributing it.